So the other thing is a same sex marriage.
There's the other thing that I think that we disagree with.
Well I we agree with the marriage thing,
right?
[inaudible] government should be involved.
They all,
I think where people should be protected is through assets and you know,
the contract.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that that all makes sense to me,
that all that style in terms of like a alimony and child support and all those
things make sense to me.
And that then the idea that the community reinforces it,
which would then become the government reinforce and all that stuff.
That all makes sense to me.
I understand it.
But um,
why do you care if a two gay guys want to get married?
Um,
so from a religious point of view,
sure.
Let's go from the legislature.
So you want them to a secular point of view first.
So the,
the idea is not that I care deeply whether two gay guys want to get married to
each other.
The idea is that it do I prefer traditional marriage to say to same sex
marriage.
Okay.
Well,
let me,
let me phrase it this way.
What do you think a gay guy is?
Do you think someone's there making a choice or do you think that this is how
they were?
So the religious point of view on this and,
and I think this is actually just the general conservative point of view on
human action generally is,
I don't know,
meaning that for the vast majority of people,
I would assume that they have a biological drive to engage in that behavior.
But the traditional sort of we'll point of view is that biological drive does
not necessarily match up to the activity you ought to engage in.
Right.
Men,
for example,
have a biological drive to impregnate many women.
That's not something religion is cool with either.
All right,
so the,
the idea is that
red balloon religion is cool with the man being with one woman and impregnating
her.
But you're not cool with a man being with a man.
So I can give you the religious explanation than I can give you the secular
explanation.
So they,
so the religious explanation is that there is something different about a woman
than there is about a man and a man is made better through his union with a
woman.
And that if you pervert the sex drive to pursue mere pleasure instead of a
lasting relationship upon which the basis of society is built,
then you are foregoing the proper use of your sex drive.
Right.
I you wanted to step in and argue against that.
You would say that just because someone can't get pregnant doesn't mean that
they don't have a loving relationship that contributes to society.
Well that's true,
but it is also for going the more productive relationship of being able to bear
and rear children and also,
and also we recognize that the sentence are not different right then and
recognizing all of the sexes are not the same.
So you know,
being with a man is in a relationship different than being with a woman.
I would assume.
I mean the item,
that's why gay guys are gay.
If it weren't,
then I assume that they would be fine with being with a woman.
Right.
So that's,
so that relationship from a,
from a religious perspective is more valuable because women have different
qualities than men.
You round off each other's harsh edges,
it changes you.
I mean,
you're married.
Being married changes Amanda in a different way.
That being married to a member of the same sex would write,
but I don't want people to have to do it.
But if you're immediate,
we're not forcing anybody.
Right.
But I want them to have the option.
If you're a gay person and
we sit tight,
don't know.
No,
I mean of course we agree,
right?
Yeah.
Illegal and I keep making this distinction because whenever I talk about my
moral perspective on things,
then people immediately assume that I'm a theocratic fascist and I just want to
keep underscoring,
yes.
My personal views on Dave Rubin's marriage are of no consequence to public
policy in any way whatsoever.
But I agree with you on that and I don't think it should be a part of public
public policy and I think people should absolutely be allowed to marry and
divorce and do whatever the fuck they want to do no matter who it is.
But why do you care?
Like as a person who's a rational thinker,
it's pretty clear that people are gay and I don't really think that this is a
decision they make in term in terms of like I'm going to make a clear choice to
defy God and be gay.
I think they're just gay.
But again,
I think that's a confliction.
It's everyone.
It's a conflation of identity and drive with activity,
which is something that religion fundamentally reject,
right?
So religion fundamentally rejects the idea that you are driven to do something,
therefore it is your identity.
Therefore he gets to participate in a behavior.
That's it.
That's a chain of thinking that religion,
religion,
if a man is gay in your religion,
if a man is gay and they're in love with another man,
they should just squash those thoughts and find a woman.
Well,
ideally they would be honest with a woman they marry and they're not like
bolusing would want.
Ideally you would still get married and have children in heterosexual
relationship.
If you're not up to that,
then you wouldn't get married at all.
When you describe this to a gay man,
they will tell you,
imagine Ben Shapiro,
someone said to you,
you should stop being with your beautiful wife and you need to now marry a man
because this is what God wants you to do,
so you're going to have to strip this man and he's going to stop you because
this is how the rules are set up so far.
This sounds pretty terrible,
right?
Well,
this is how it sounds to gay folks when you're telling them they have to find a
woman and like I like,
I'm not saying you have to find a woman.
I'm saying this guy.
I'm saying you can't do X.
Right?
I'm not saying you must but say can't,
but by whose determination?
If you decide to participate in this religion,
right?
Then there is a buy in to the precepts of the religion and the buy in is campy
gay?
Well,
no.
The buy in is that you can have whatever sexual orientation you please,
but there are certain activity you can't participate in,
so you can be gay,
but you can't have gay sex.
Correct.
That's that.
By the way,
that's what the Bible,
I mean,
if we want to go direct to the texts from the Bible,
it's what the Bible actually says,
right?
I mean,
even the parts of the Bible that people really hate those parts say that a man
shall not lie with a man.
It doesn't say a man can't be attracted to another man.
That's Old Testament,
right?
Isn't that right?
That's our stuff,
right?
New Testament.
It gets a little harsher in the new testament in some places,
Romans Corinthians,
but in any case,
you know,
again,
when it comes to this is what I'm puzzled by is the idea that this is a unique
area of human behavior that religion is supposed to treat differently,
meaning religion traits.
Virtually every human activity like this sin is a failure to abide by a
covenant.
That's what,
that's the definition of sin,
right?
Right.
When you commit a sin in Judaism and Avera and Judaism,
what you are doing is failing to do a Mitzvah,
which is a commandment.
You're violating a commandment.
Well there are lots of commandments that go directly against what people are
driven to do just because of the drive is stronger,
does not make it morally more morally non culpable to violate that commandment.
So w w when people pick this one out and they say,
well this one is particularly intolerant for example,
uh,
I,
I don't see why it's more particularly intolerant than saying to a man that you
have to marry one woman or saying to a Jew that you are not allowed to eat this
stuff.
Or you know,
like it's,
it may be harder.
I think there's any question.
It's harder to abide by those commandments,
but it is well within religious tradition,
like literally every religious tradition that there's a bunch of stuff you are
driven to do that you can't.
Now,
again,
you don't have to agree with my program.
I'm not trying to convert you is one of the nice things about my religion.
I don't give a crap whether people are Jewish or not.
Like we,
we actively discourage convert.
But if you're going to proclaim that you are abiding by traditional Judaism,
this is the buy in,
right?
There's lots of buy and you have to wear a funny hat.
Sometimes you have to,
you have to go to shul on Saturdays.
You have to keep Shabbat.
Like there's,
there's a lot of buy in and as long as I'm not bothering anybody else,
I,
I frankly don't see what business it is legitimately anybody's what I think
about personal relationships.
I'm not imposing my view on anybody else.
Well,
um,
I I do acknowledge that all the religions,
Judaism probably makes it the most obvious.
They don't give a fuck what you do.
Go ahead.
Do your thing.
Like they're not trying to prove that you're doing your business side converted
and uh,
when he'd get very,
it was a grind man.
He had to learn a lot of shit,
like three years of a grind.
A long time.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's a long time.
So that was the religious
perspective on the and the secular perspective when it comes to valuing
traditional marriage over over a same sex marriage,
that's a very simple calculation,
which is one type of marriage produces traditional children,
produces children need traditional biological way,
and then you have both parents in the house to take care of the kid,
right?
That's the value of marriage and I fully acknowledge that when the value of
marriage shifted from,
it's about production and rearing of children too.
It's two people who love each other.
The case for same sex marriage against same sex marriage went completely out the
window.
Right.
So you are just sticking to your rigid ideology in terms of like what you
believe to be a sin and not believed to be a sin based on your religion,
based on this very strict moral fiber that this religion is operating in a
religious context.
Just to me it applies to my family.
It doesn't apply to you.
Right.
Is there any room for growth in that when people have a better understanding
about biology like it,
so if it was proven,
if there's proven like,
oh,
this is why a person develops blue eyes.
This is why a person is gay.
This is why this is nothing wrong with it.
It's just a very,
it's red hair,
it's freckles,
it's gay,
it's straight.
Tell me that that homosexual orientation is 100% biologically driven and I will
almost completely agree with that.
I think that there's some cases where it's not,
but those are rare,
but it's particularly true by the way.
The research tends to show that there's more sexual fluidity among females than
males.
Males.
It tends to be either heterosexual or homicide.
Should I research is all done by dudes want their wife to hook up with chairs.
Go on,
tell him,
tell him to stop you.
But let me just show you the paperwork.
But if I'm wrong,
but
again,
that it's a question that I've always found actually not particularly
interesting simply because it doesn't take into account the worldview generally,
which is that a biological drive does not equal excuse for behaving in a certain
way.
But that's where it brings me back to this.
Like is it possible that these laws in this religion were written when there
what?
I mean,
who do you think wrote the stuff?
Do you think people wrote the stuff or do you think God wrote?
I think either way,
even if it were it.
I mean,
because I am a an orthodox Jew,
I believe that at the very least it's got inspired and God written.
Right?
But even if I believed on a second level that human beings are at that stuff
too.
I think that people 3000 years ago had never seen a gay person before.
[inaudible] like the very reason to have a commandment is because certain people
in your community are behaving in a particular way,
presumably.
Right?
There's no commandment not to take your head and shove it into meat grinder.
Well,
this is also the argument against pork.
It's because they didn't understand trick hypnosis.
Then understand you have to cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork parasites,
which are very dangerous for people.
So
I,
I'm,
I'm not a huge fan of naturalistic explanations for religion.
Do I think that's a good one though for pork?
I mean,
I don't know.
Like I think you could make an argument maybe that
died in India and there's horrific x rays of his head.
He had parasites from pork that had gotten into his body and they had a nested
in his brain,
started developing all these cysts inside of his head and they couldn't do
anything about it because it was so deep in his head that if they gave him the
antiviral antiparasitic medication,
it would cause swelling of the brain and then they're like,
it was,
it was so sad I feel about that far gone.
He held the story.
It's actually pig shit.
Apparently people accidentally coming in contact with pig shit produces this
particular type of parasite.
Yeah,
that's not kosher.
It's more rare,
but trickle gnosis was pretty common for a long time.
There are attempts to sort of paint back into the Bible's certain rationalistic
explanations like this where it makes sense though.
Um,
I,
I think,
why else would you,
would it be bad?
He pigs,
like Jesus loves pigs.
Is that what's going on?
Uh,
well,
I,
I think that the,
the reversal of the kosher laws in the New Testament,
you know,
from,
from a Jewish point of view,
or we don't believe in the divinity of Christ right there,
you can make an argument that the,
the Gospels,
which were written profit and significant,
no,
we don't even believe he's a prophet.
What do you think he was?
What are you guys doing?
I mean,
I,
what I,
what do I think he was historically,
I think he was a Jew who tried to lead a revolt against the Romans and got
killed for his trouble.
Just like a lot of other Jews at that time who were crucified for trying to lead
revolted against the Roman and got killed for their trouble.
So he became legend and story and it became a bigger and bigger deal as time
for followers.
And then that gradually grew.
And then do you think they were says rejected?
No,
that's not,
that's not a Jewish belief.
Okay.
I just want to check.
Yeah,
no,
or we're not into American stories.
No,
that's missing it now.
You don't have any miracles.
No,
not,
not.
Not by Jesus.
And they're the ones in the old testament.
Yeah.
You've gotten most of splitting the sea and all that.
What do you think happened there?
What do I think happened there?
Yeah.
Well,
I'll go with,
to my mind at d and explanation that there was a,
I mean it says in the Bible there was a strong east wind,
so there's a naturalistic explanation for a physical phenomenon that makes
sense.
I mean,
that's,
so that's what my mind is constantly trying to do is read nature back into the
Bible.
Mm.
Yeah.
That,
that is the problem with these texts,
right?
Is it,
you're trying to decipher translations from original tax,
which are written in h and Hebrew thousands of years ago and were told in oral
tradition for longer than that.
Right,
right.
I mean,
this is,
this is where,
you know,
my,
my book,
which I always hesitate to pitch my own stuff because it sounds Gauche pitch
away,
but the new book,
the right side of history,
number one,
New York Times bestselling man fiction books,
wait a minute.
You got number one in the New York Times bestselling fee.
Really?
Yeah.
We sold enough that we knocked Michelle Obama out of the number one slot for a
week.
So that was nice.
Is there a protest?
Uh,
well,
no protests yet,
but suffice it to say the New York Times book review or didn't like it,
but I'm not super shocked by that.
But the basic contention that I make is that Judeo Christian values on the one
hand and then human reason on the other Greek reason really,
that that tradition is attention and that that tension is where western
civilization lives.
That basically civilization is a suspension bridge.
It takes certain fundamental precepts of Judaeo Christian values on the one hand
and then takes Greek reason and they're pulling against each other and sometimes
reason feels like it's going to dominate religion.
And sometimes it feels like religion is going to dominate reason.
But in the best of all available worlds,
you have a bridge that is,
that is capable of building upon that where you can actually have a functional
civilization.
And if you lose reason in the name of theocracy,
then you end up with tyrannical theocracy.
And if you lose,
if you lose religion in the name of reason,
you end up in some pretty dark places because human beings don't have a very
good track record of creating their own purpose,
creating their own meaning,
creating their own systems.
We tend to get very utopian very quickly,
right?
And things get really ugly,
which is sort of the story of the,
particularly the first half of the 20th century.
So this is the benefit of sticking to the rigid ideology that's prescribed by
religion,
is that you don't allow the human beings to keep updating it and changing it.
Because if you do,
they will eventually slide into chaos.
Yes.
But there's there,
which is not to say there's not play in the joints,
right?
I mean there's certainly religion has morphed over time.
Of course,
Judaism as it was practiced originally,
probably in many ways does not resemble Judaism is practiced now.
Right.
And in fact,
the Tom Wood even says this,
I mean there's,
there's this kind of fascinating and counter intuitive section of the time I'd
wear,
um,
Moses is,
it's,
it's uh,
what is called the to tie,
which some of these stories that are just kind of put into the,
into the middle of the Telmate where Moses comes back and he's watching from on
high as a bunch of rabbis in,
you know,
second century Palestine,
uh,
are,
are talking about Judaism.
And he's like,
I don't recognize any of this stuff.
Like I brought down these books,
the mountain,
and I do not recognize any of this stuff.
And,
and God says to him,
you know,
it,
God says to him,
right?
I mean,
this is how this is more often.
Moses is pleased.
In other words,
he's,
he's not.
Judaism has always had a common law tradition where you're using reason to try
and develop the ideas behind the commandments and then try and extend them or
broaden them.
And I think that's a good thing.
But you have to be careful not to completely undermine fundamental routes or,
or get rid of basic precepts.
In other words,
you have to,
you have to acknowledge there are certain fundamental truths that exist there.
And then there's play as far as how those are implemented.
Does Judaism have one of those?
Pray the gay away traditions?
No,
that's not it.
That's not a thing.
I mean it's,
what do they want guys to do?
Like what say what would you do if not better
not to,
not to sin but again soon as a soon as a thing that everybody does.
Meaning that masturbation is not,
is not okay.
According to Judaism,
I assume that a vast majority of young Jewish men,
even the Orthodox are masturbating.
So people sit and I mean that's,
that's a recognition.
It's always,
again,
I think I can speak on behalf of,
I will audaciously speak on behalf of both Jews and Christians here.
I think that religious people are are told that when they say that something is
a sin,
this means that they are looking at scans at the people who are committing the
sin and that is not correct.
I mean what Judaism and Christianity say is that we are all committing sins on a
fairly regular basis.
Where we get uptight is when people start saying,
because I have a desire for the sin,
the sin is no longer a sin.
Hmm.
Yeah.
The real problem is like what?
Why is it a sin ACC who says it's a sin?
So again,
who again,
this these rules you were assuming are influenced by God,
right,
but clearly written by people.
Well,
the
this one you would say if you're a fundamentalist or at least somebody who
believes in the,
the idea that the Torah was given by God was given literally by God.
But again,
that doesn't the logic behind the roles which you know,
people like my monities have tried to explicate.
The idea is,
as I said a second,
this you can do without God,
right?
This part he can do without God.
The human sex drive was made to procreate within a stable relationship in order
to pro generate and have future generations of people misuse of that sex drive
in any way,
whether you're talking about from masturbation to homosexual activity is
therefore a diminishment of the use of that drive.
That's the natural law case against,
against homosexual activity.
And again,
I will reiterate for media matters for the 1000000th time,
I'm not in favor of any of this being encoded into American law because freedom
is freedom.
People should be able to sit in how they choose so long as they're not harming
anyone else.
Right?
No.
But what about people that have had vasectomies and what about women that also
Judaism is not called this ectomies not cool with it,
but neither is Catholicism from what I understand.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not a big fan of that one either
then when I have more experience with.
But uh,
so if,
what if a man is in the woman's sterile,
are they allowed to have sex?
They both know.
So yes,
because there are ancillary benefits to married couples having sex,
like relationship building.
Right.
But that's not a generalized case against the favored view of sex.
Fit.
That's sort of like arguing that intersex people mean that there's no such thing
as two separate sexes.
There are two separate Texas and also their intersex people who have a
condition.
Yes.
Right.
And that's the same thing here.
The,
the case in favor of heterosexual sexual activity does not change based on the
fact that some people can't actually participate in that.
What would you do if a young gay guy came to you for advice?
If someone said,
hey,
Ben,
a,
I'm in an admirer of yours.
I love the way you think and follow your philosophies,
but I've got a problem.
I'm a young Jewish man and I'm gay and I don't know what to do.
What would you tell them to do?
I mean I can't tell them to do anything.
Right.
Advice.
Would you tell?
Would you tell them to not act out on those feelings?
I would say you do the best you can as a human being and from my moral
perspective,
you try to avoid sin as best you can,
but everybody's sins.
The problem does that sin though it seems to me that it was defined by people
that didn't understand biology because they were dealing with humans that
existed thousands of years ago.
No,
no understanding of why people were gay.
Well,
I mean I again,
I,
I really don't think that biblical commandments are linked and religious
commandments generally are linked to a view of biology.
Meaning that you don't think so?
No.
I think that all sin is a recognition that we have drives that we are supposed
to forego.
Okay.
That's pretty much,
I mean that's,
that's fundamental to certainly Judaism to Christianity as well.
I would say Islam even has,
has this basic precept,
right?
When I think we can agree that there's some real benefits to discipline,
has real benefits to having structure.
And it doesn't mean that you can't be creative.
It doesn't mean that you can't be free and do whatever you want some of the time
too.
But I think we can both agree that this is one of the,
one of the best benefits of an ideology and what hopefully a positive ideology.
Right.
And one of the things that I,
the reason I keep coming back to the governmental regulation point is because my
view is that if your view of discipline is not my view,
discipline good on you,
right?
Like go,
go do what you want to do.
Like I've never had a conversation with Dave Ruben about,
about him being a gay guy.
Right.
But you did say that you like wouldn't go to his marriage.
Right?
Well,
I see it right.
As a,
as a religious person,
I can't say I can't actively participate in something that I consider to be a
sin,
but I would go out to dinner with Dave and his husband anytime,
like my wife and I would do that.
Of course we'd have over to our house with his husband.
Does.
No,
you don't find any contradiction between your religious perspective and your
personal perspective in that regard that you would do?
You wouldn't be there for religious reasons,
but that you would be there for personal reasons.
Like if it wasn't,
would you go to the after party?
Like if you wouldn't go to the wedding,
would you go to the APP?
Anything that was a celebration of same sex marriage now.
Wow.
So anything but like if we go to the party,
no,
I mean is it,
and that's it.
That there there's a barbecue the next day when a tag
and again like I'm not sure why I'm not a good party person,
so I'm not sure why anybody would want me at their party.
Frankly.
I'm kind of a buzzkill but haven't been to a party with you.
But I went to a dinner party with you.
That's true.
We had a great time.
That was a good time.
That was good times.
That's a funny picture,
man.
That is a wild,
don't know what the fuck to think about that picture.
That is certainly true.
Eric and Jordan and Sam,
you and I.
It's like,
what's your premise?
Just in one place right.